Did you know that there are unbelievable research
papers on how simulate the life of virtual trees?
We can write a computer program to simulate
how they move by interacting with them with a
mouse. If we go too hard, we can simulate
how they break, and if we feel like it,
we can even burn a tree down. Or simulate not
one burning tree, but even an entire forest.
Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Now, for a more peaceful simulation,
we can simulate the life of complete
ecosystems for a thousand years as well.
This is a story of human ingenuity. Yes,
all of these were handcrafted techniques,
no AI of any sort was used to make this.
And I have good news for you Fellow Scholars.
We have even more papers in this area,
and I have found some new ones that
are beyond amazing. For instance,
the previous works showed what happens above
the ground, but a great deal of a tree’s life
also happens underground. As this poplar
tree develops over time, so do its roots
as well. Now take a careful look at the shape
of the roots. And now, have a look at this pine
tree growing. Wow. The poplar went vertical, the
pine went horizontal. Now, why does this happen?
Well, poplar trees are rapid-growing
but relatively short-lived trees and
they primarily grow in areas where water is
deeper down in the soil, and with these roots,
they can reach them. Now, the pine sees the world
entirely differently. Its roots are horizontal,
thus maximizing water and nutrient absorption
near the surface. And as an additional bonus,
it gets stabilized in unfriendly environments
where the soil is looser. Very smart.
Now, what about the oak? The oak a wise tree and
what does a wise tree do? Of course, diversifies
its bets. Its deep taproot system gives it access
to deep water sources, but it also has widespread
horizontal roots for maximum nutrient absorption,
thus giving it great longevity. Great choice.
Hmm…I feel a bit like David
Attenborough here. However,
the story does not end here. A good tree root
simulation has to take into consideration how
smart and adaptable these little plants are.
You see, environmental stimulus matters a great
deal in their development. For instance,
when growing around the slope of a hill,
it recognizes that it will need a different
kind of root system to survive. Loving it!
So, is that it? Is that all this simulator can
take into consideration? Well, not quite. Now
hold on to your papers and look at this Fellow
Scholars. Holy mother of papers! It simulates the
effect of all of these parameters, and this
is not even a complete list. For instance,
it simulates how different kinds of soils
exist and show a different growth resistance
factor. And we can also mix them up, so it can
simulate heterogeneous systems. What does that
mean? Multiple soil types scattered across
this virtual world. Absolutely beautiful.
And the tree will grow as a tree should grow
in reality. Hopefully. And as we change the
distribution of soil types, so does this
wise little tree adapt to its environment.
It even learns to avoid regions of
high growth resistance and it grows
around it. Thus simulating
asymmetric growth. So good!
Now, I wonder how much computation
does such a simulation take? I mean,
we need to simulate these little virtual
trees for years and years. Does it take years
and years of computation time in real life?
Look at that! Not at all. Fellow Scholars,
we can simulate such a system on the scale
of months in a matter of seconds. Simulating
60k little roots in less than 3 seconds.
And sometimes, even interactively. Wow.
Now at this point I have one more
question left. You know what it
is. Are these simulations for show, or is this
how reality works? Well, let’s see about that.
When compared to a previous paper that
digitizes tree root systems in real life,
this is the real deal. Now, does this simulator
live up to these results? Look at that. My
goodness! Clean sweep. Loving it. Not only
the kinds of structures are very similar,
but I actually have to look real close to find
the differences. It needn’t be perfect, and yet,
it almost is. Wow. And it gets better. The
root and shoot ratios for real trees are known,
and the simulated oak’s properties are
very similar the ones seen in real trees.
And now, imagine that the games and virtual
worlds of the future could be with simulations
that are this realistic. We could play in these
worlds in the future. What a time to be alive!
And once again, all this
was done through sheer human
ingenuity. No AI technique was used in this paper.
And the paper contains so much more analysis, you
simply have to take a look. A beautiful piece of
work. Of course it is, because this is a SIGGRAPH
paper. What is that? SIGGRAPH is the most sacred
place for some of the best computer graphics
papers ever. Getting a paper accepted there
is in my opinion, like winning the olympic gold
medal of graphics research. Huge congratulations.
However, computer graphics is a field that is
orders of magnitude smaller than AI research.
For instance, look at this. Goodness. This paper
was seen by about 200 Fellow Scholars. And I fear
that if we don’t talk about works like this here
on Two Minute Papers, almost no one will. Here,
I try to be a good ambassador of computer
graphics research and show everyone how
amazing these papers are and they can give to the
world so much. And it breaks my heart that so few
people know about them. And good news, I have more
papers like this up the sleeve. If you wish to not
miss out on them when they come in the future,
make sure to subscribe and hit the bell icon.